NEARLY 70 YEARS LATER, NO ONE
HAS BEEN HELD CRIMINALLY
RESPONSIBLE.
>>> A TEENAGER IN NEBRASKA AND
HER MOTHER ARE FACING MULTIPLE
CHARGES AFTER FACEBOOK'S PARENT
COMPANY META TURNED OVER THEIR
PRIVATE MESSAGES.
POLICE SAY THEIR MESSAGES PROVE
THE TEEN HAD AN ILLEGAL ABORTION
THAT SHE AND HER MOTHER TOLD
POLICE IT WAS AN UNEXPECTED
STILLBIRTH.
THIS CASE IS TRAGIC INDEPENDENT
OF THE TECHNOLOGICAL ELEMENTS.
IT'S RAISING SOME ALARMS ABOUT
PRIVACY FOR SOME.
>> YEAH.
WE'VE SEEN PRIVACY EXPERTS WHO
HAVE BEEN RAISING ALARM BELLS
ABOUT HOW YOUR PERSONAL DATA,
YOUR APPS AND INTERNET SEARCHES,
MIGHT BE USED TO ENFORCE THE
RESTRICTIVE ABORTION LAWS WE'VE
SEEN GO INTO EFFECT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
THIS CASE RELATES TO LAWS
ALREADY ON THE BOOKS, EVEN
BEFORE THE SUPREME COURT'S
DECISION.
NEBRASKA LIMITS ABORTIONS TO THE
FIRST 20 WEEKS.
IN NEBRASKA, POLICE WERE
INVESTIGATING A MOTHER AND HER
TEENAGE DAUGHTER AND A PREGNANCY
THAT ENDED AT 28 WEEKS.
IT WAS CALLED A STILLBIRTH BY
THE MOTHER AND THE DAUGHTER.
POLICE BELIEVE THEY WERE
INVESTIGATING AN ILLEGAL
ABORTION.
THEY CHARGED THE MOTHER AND THE
DAUGHTER IN THE COURSE OF THEIR
INVESTIGATION AFTER FILING SOME
CHARGES.
THEY CONTINUED TO INTERVIEW THE
DAUGHTER WHO THEN REFERENCED HER
FACEBOOK MESSAGES TO TRY TO
PINPOINT SOME INFORMATION.
AT THAT POINT, IT SEEMS POLICE
SOUGHT A WARRANT FOR INFORMATION
PERTAINING TO BOTH THE DAUGHTER
AND MOTHER'S FACEBOOK ACCOUNTS.
THAT INFORMATION WAS THEN TURNED
OVER TO POLICE.
POLICE ALSO THEN SOUGHT ANOTHER
WARRANT PERTAINING TO INTERNET
SEARCHES RELATED TO MEDICATION
ABORTIONS.
THEY SEIZED 13 DEVICES FROM THE
FAMILY.
FACEBOOK HAS PUT OUT A
STATEMENT.
THEY SAY THAT NOTHING IN THE
VALID COURTS WERE RECEIVED LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT IN JUNE PRIOR TO
THE SUPREME COURT DECISION
MENTIONED ABORTION.
THIS IS A CASE WITH A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION AND FACEBOOK
TURNED OTHER THE INFORMATION
HERE AFTER WARRANTS WERE SOUGHT.
YOU'RE SEEING DATA BEING USED TO
PROSECUTE THE CASES.
IT'S SOMETHING WE COULD SEE A
LOT MORE OF ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
SHOULD NOTE HERE THAT BOTH
MOTHER AND DAUGHTER PLEADED NOT
GUILTY TO ALL CHARGES.
>> THANK YOU FOR THAT.
>>> LET'S GO TO THE ACTING
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
NATIONAL ADVOCATES FOR PREGNANT
WOMEN.
FIRST YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS STORY.
AS I SAID, TRAGIC INDEPENDENT OF
FACEBOOK OR META HANDING OVER
THE INFORMATION IN RESPONSE TO
THIS WARRANT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE
IMPLICATIONS ARE BEYOND THE
SINGULAR CASE?
>> WELL, I THINK WHAT WE SEE
HERE IS QUITE A TYPICAL
PLAYBOOK, UNFORTUNATELY.
MOST CASES OF PREGNANCY-RELATED
CRIMINALIZATION START WITH THE
REPORT FROM ANOTHER PERSON.
NOT FROM SURVEILLING DIGITAL
INFORMATION.
IN THIS CASE, WHAT WE UNDERSTAND
IS THAT SOMEONE THAT WAS KNOWN
TO THE FAMILY REPORTED SOMETHING
SUSPICIOUS ABOUT THIS PREGNANCY
LOSS TO THE POLICE.
THAT'S WHAT KICKED OFF THE CHAIN
OF EVENTS.
IN OUR RESEARCH AND THE CASES
WHICH WE REPRESENTED FOLKS, IT'S
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS, IT'S
NEIGHBORS, IT'S FAMILY MEMBERS
WHO MAKE THAT INITIAL REPORT.
THAT'S HOW THIS CASE ALSO --
>> I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT META
SAID THAT THE INITIAL WARRANT
DID NOT MENTION ABORTION.
IT DOESN'T GO ON TO SAY IF IT
HAD BEEN MENTIONED ABORTION WE
WOULD HAVE FOUGHT THIS SEARCH
WARRANT OR REQUEST.
ARE YOU FINDING THAT COMPANIES
ARE FIGHTING THESE TO PROTECT
THEIR CUSTOMERS?
ESPECIALLY ON THE ISSUES OF
ABORTION OR THE RIGHT TO?
>> WELL, I THINK WHAT IS
IMPORTANT IS FOR COMPANIES TO
TAKE A PRINCIPLED POSITION
SURROUNDING WHAT THEY WILL DO,
IF THEY ARE MADE AWARE OF A
SEARCH WARRANT OR OTHER REQUESTS
FOR INFORMATION THAT RELATE TO
HEALTH CARE-RELATED CRIMES.
AND I WANT TO ALSO JUST POINT
OUT THIS SAME SITUATION COULD
ARISE WITH RESPECT TO GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE IN CERTAIN
STATES.
IT FINDS ITSELF IN THE CROSS
HAIRS RIGHT NOW.
IF FACEBOOK HAD INFORMATION
RELATING TO THE UNDERLYING
FACTS, THEY REALLY NEEDED TO
SCRUTINIZE THOSE FACTS AND
UNDERSTAND THAT A CHARGE OR AN
INVESTIGATION DOESN'T HAVE TO
ARTICULATE A STATUTE THAT
RELATES TO AN ABORTION OR
ABORTION BAN.
MOST OF THE CASES WE'VE WORKED
ON AND BEEN TRACKING INVOLVED
PROSECUTIONS OF OTHER CRIMES.
WHAT WE'VE SEEN FELON CHILD KNEE
NEGLECT, MURDER, MANSLAUGHTER.
WE EXPECT THOSE KINDS OF CHARGES
TO INCREASE IN THE POST DOBBS
WORLD.
>> ABSENT THE POLICIES YOU'RE
CALLING FOR FROM THESE TECH
COMPANIES, WHAT SHOULD WOMEN DO?
SHOULD THEY STOP USING THE
PERIOD-TRACKING APPS OR NOT
DISCUSS THIS ONLINE?
HOW FAR ARE YOU SUGGESTING WOMEN
GO TO PROTECT THEMSELVES FROM
SOMETHING LIKE THIS POTENTIALLY
HAPPENING TO THEM?
>> WELL, I'M RELUCTANT TO DEMAND
THAT EVERY DAY REGULAR PEOPLE
HAVE TO MONITOR WHO THEY SPEAK
TO OR KEEP THE INFORMATION AS
CONFIDENTIAL AS POSSIBLE.
MANY PEOPLE ARE GOING THROUGH A
DIFFICULT TIME MAKING THE
DECISIONS AND ACCESSING
INFORMATION.
YOU COULD DELETE YOUR
PERIOD-TRACKING APP.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF ATTENTION
ON THAT.
MORE IMPORTANTLY USE ENCRYPTED
MESSAGING SERVICES LIKE SIGNAL.
USE SEARCH ENGINES THAT DON'T
TRACK OR RETAIN SEARCH
INFORMATION.
I THINK WE ALSO NEED TO CALL
UPON THE MAJOR PLATFORMS TO NOT
RETAIN SEARCH INFORMATION THAT
RELATES TO HEALTH CARE.
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO THE
INFORMATION.
THEY DON'T NEED TO HOLD ON TO
IT.
THEY SHOULD TAKE THE POSITION